all right I am seriously psyched to do
this interview right now I have truly
one of my heroes from wrestling back in
the 80s to movies to politics and now a
guy that I truly truly admire and he's
off the grid which is why I'm wearing
these crazy headphones and we're doing
this on some super crazy high tech
connection governor Jesse Ventura how
are you sir
Dave I'm doing terrific how are you
doing I am doing well I cannot begin to
tell you the technical hurdles that we
had to jump through to make this happen
but that is the proof that you truly are
off the grid so can you tell us a little
bit about that just first off well I'm
uh I'm off the grid I decided to do this
right after I left office as governor
because I was young enough to go on an
adventure and I decided to do it and so
we ventured down here way down south of
the border about a thousand miles and I
bought a home that I'm an hour from
pavement and an hour from electricity
and I've been living down here now
off and on for going on eight years and
now that I have this show I may be down
here permanently with not returning to
the United States soon because I love it
down here off the grid I love the people
where I live and it's now the creation
of my show broadcasting back into
America as opposed to looking at America
from the outside looking in
as opposed the inside looking out yes so
why does someone who has commercial
success as an actor and a wrestler and
then who has political success
staggering political success actually
why do you feel that you had to go off
the grid well I didn't feel I have to
but I just felt I wanted an adventure I
was turning at the time I would just
gone over 50 and your window of
opportunity and time it got to the point
Dave I'll give it to your blunt yeah
when you get to my age at about 60 years
old 62 I am now time becomes more
important than money and so that was the
reason I did it I wanted to go on the
adventure and it has been that and now I
it's paid off because I have the show
off the grid and you know we're in a
situation right now
where have you criticized the US
government they might
kill you with a drone because they don't
well they don't have to take you to
court anymore they don't have to charge
you with a crime they don't have to go
through due process at all they can just
shoot you and kill you with a drone if
you come become a problem so we got to
keep moving down here off the grid to
stay away from those drones right so
this is the stuff that we talk about all
the time over here but you're actually
living if you actually felt that I guess
you have enough influence or your voice
is powerful enough that you actually
felt I assume some sort of threat either
not maybe not spoken but just sort of
unspoken is that fair to say oh no I
never got threatened but I was I was
being blackballed out there the last
book tour the last book tour I did none
of the networks NBC CBS or ABC would
have me on Fox won't have me on MSNBC
won't have me on CNN has me on
occasionally so this presented an
opportunity what happened I was doing a
book tour and I saw in my schedule Larry
King and I thought wait a minute Larry
retired what's this and I walked into a
hotel in New York and there was Larry
King yeah Larry said I'm on he said I'm
on aura dot TV this is where you need to
be and so we started discussing it and I
explained to them I said well there's a
problem I live off the grid for four to
five months a year how could I possibly
do a show for you and they said that's
not a problem we have state-of-the-art
technology they said as long as we got
energy and as we get a clear shot at the
satellite we can do your show from
anywhere in the world and so that's how
often and then off the grid became the
show we thought then let's make that the
show that we're off the grid
broadcasting back to the United States
much the same I don't know if you're old
enough to remember but when Wolfman Jack
first hit the famous shock jock dis jock
way before Howard Stern the mystique
about the Wolfman with all the teenage
kids I remember it was that that they
wouldn't let the Wolfman broadcast from
the United States so he had the
broadcast from Mexico into the United
States and that's what we all believed
as teenagers about the Wolfman so I'm
just kind of you
the ol Wolfman Jack thing here I'm going
outside the country for real and
broadcasting back in all right well so
let's talk about that though the heart
of why you're outside of the country I
mean I think you see this this country
much the way I see it it's it's a
country that you love and you want to be
better but seems really broken right now
right totally I blame the Democrats and
Republicans both of them equally as bad
as each other they are the problem they
are not the solution they have been in
charge for a hundred and fifty years now
look at the shape we're in I just saw
statistically Dave the other day a baby
born when it takes its first breath of
air in the United States on birth is
$50,000 in debt 50 grand in debt when
you take your first breath air who's
responsible for this the Democrats and
Republicans they've been in charge for
150 years they've destroyed our country
and we've got to take it back from him
yeah
so speaking of taking it back so you
were someone that you started taking it
back because you as an independent at
the time became governor of Minnesota
which in retrospect does that almost
seem crazy to you that that actually
worked because now it almost seems like
we could never have an independent not
true at all not I prove that it does
work and we only raised $300,000 Dave
yeah 98 to elect me governor 300 gram I
actually made more money being governor
than what I spent to get it I don't
think there's another elected official
nationally who can make that statement
in 50 years yeah that they made more
money doing the job than what they spent
to get it no it could happen I'll tell
you right now I'll make you bold here we
are on Dave's program I'll give you a
bold prediction that if I could if I
could get ballot access in all 50 states
and if I were guaranteed to be allowed
in the debates I would be your next
president in 2016
listen I'm with you you have my support
I'll do everything I can all right so
let I want to talk about some of the
some of the other more fun stuff let's
get out of politics for a minute
tonight I just
watch the running man this week and at
the beginning of it there is this
preamble where they talk about what
America is going to be like in 2017 and
it's about a militarized state and an
economic collapse and depleted natural
resource and I'm watching this thing and
they're they're just three years off
because it's basically happening now did
you realize that that movie although we
have it we don't have reality jail just
yet but I think we probably will reality
TV jail do you realize that movie was
gonna be so ahead of its time no really
I didn't you know it was a fun movie to
do with richard dawson and arnold and
all that because the premise of the show
did you know who actually wrote the
running man are you aware of that
you know what i did my research before
and i don't remember offhand tell me
please
well here's no well here's the deal the
running man was a short story written in
a book by a writer named Richard Bachman
mm-hmm well that was a pseudonym for
Stephen King Stephen King wrote the
running man is that right I can't
believe it you know what when I was when
I was doing research before I watched it
again the other day I would have sworn
it was a philip k dick because that was
all his his future and nope yeah nope
Stephen King Stephen King wrote under
the pseudonym of Richard Bachman and he
wrote the running man and what it is
it's a game show of the future well with
reality TV like it is today and when you
look at where we're at right now in 2017
the running man might be real it's three
years away yeah really between ratings
and our for-profit prisons which we
already have it definitely as a
possibility so I got to ask you when you
did that movie and you did predator both
with Arnold Schwarzenegger did you guys
ever do you have a political talk did
you ever say yeah you know what maybe
maybe we'll be governors one day what do
you think not a bit you know when when
we did predator in fact I did predator
and Arnold came up to me on the set and
said Jesse my next film the running man
there's a part you're perfect for I hope
you will do it well it always get when
you deal with Hollywood and when the
star of the film wants you in his film
it gives you great leverage on
negotiating yeah to learn what when the
star wants you in the film that means
you've got some leverage when it
comes time to negotiate and believe me I
exploited that leverage well speaking of
leverage did you get to keep the gun
literally the coolest gun probably in
the history of filmmaking did they let
you keep it no not at all that's the
helicopter minigun I was the first
person in predator to shoot at handheld
it shoots seven thousand rounds a minute
I think something like that it's a it's
a Gatling gun is what it is and it I was
shooting a full ammo load it didn't kick
that much it's just torque to the left a
little because the barrel swinging
counterclockwise but the unique thing
about the gun is its electronically
fired there's no trigger they would run
battery cables up my pants leg and out
and splice it into the weapon and then
they're gonna be guy in the bushes and
was time for me to shoot
he touched the two heads to the car
batteries and I'd start firing wow that
is unbelievable what was your classic
line there do you remember it I ain't
got time to bleed there it is there it
is well I got two more things for you
because I know I know you're busy what
do you think it was about the 80s about
that time between the wrestling thing
and the movies you did what was so cool
about the 80s that so many people
obviously myself included have such like
great nostalgia for for that time well
the raid that what happened was
wrestling went national all of a sudden
it had been in 26 regionalised
territories it had come out of the
carnival world it had gone into the 26
regionalised territories and all these
promoters twenty-six of them really were
kind of like the Mafia
nobody ever crossed their lines and then
in the 80s came young Vince McMahon jr.
the son of Vince McMahon's senior while
he didn't owe nobody any Allegiance and
he had a vision and along with that came
cable television he started buying up
cable TV and he took wrestling national
and he took it to levels we never I'll
never forget the night we did NBC the
first night NBC Saturday night main
event we altered where we alternated
every three to four weeks were Saturday
Night Live and the greatest one ever was
the second season they had Madonna open
Saturday Night Live she was red-hot we
came on three weeks later and blew her
numbers right out of the water to this
day wrestling Saturday night main event
has the highest ratings for what they
call a weekend special we actually did
what was it a 34 share Wow
I mean we you know we always think about
the Golden Age of TV and and but that
really was the the Golden Age of
wrestling although it's it seems to be
having a pretty nice comeback my final
question for you I'm gonna end you on a
big one who's running the show who's
running the show I I know you're a
conspiracy guy I know you know a lot
about everything who really at the end
of the day is run is this the government
is this the Illuminati who's it running
the show you know I can't sit Dave and
tell you I can tell you who's doing it
and I used to not believe in that
Illuminati I used to not believe in
world government and that they were out
there but I've somewhat changed my mind
now in the investigations I've done and
the things I've watched and seen and I'm
62 years old now it seems to me mighty
strange I don't believe that our
president runs our country anymore
because the classic example was Barack
Obama when he ran yeah he said he would
close Gitmo he said he would do all of
these things and then the moment he got
in office those things were all
forgotten our foreign policy there's no
difference in our foreign policy between
George Bush and Barack Obama at all none
whatsoever and so somebody else and to
me it's got to be the powerful money
people it's got to be the Federal
Reserve and the bankers who control the
money because if you control the money
you control everything yeah well you
said what we talk about every day
governor Pence are truly truly truly an
honor to talk to you I could talk to you
all day but I know you've got some other
things to do off the grid for a guy
that's off the grid you're pretty busy
I'll tell you that much well I'd like I
said the tough part about being off the
grid is every day it's 85 and sunny Dave
all right not bad I I really do
appreciate it and I look forward to
following you
we'll see what happens but you've got an
ally here at the o Turks I promise you
that all right very well I appreciate
the Young Turks you guys are doing a
great job keep up the great work keep
them honest up there and between all of
us will destroy mainstream media how's
that for a wrestling interview it ready
mainstream media you're next in line
we're gonna put you down next mainstream
media